[Music]
Kendall Jenner and bad bunnies Saddle Up
do you like to ride long or short like
in between it's really exciting after
being spotted packing on the PDA last
month the model and rapper hit the
trails over the weekend with both stars
going casual Bad Bunny in a light jacket
and sneakers meanwhile Kenny Rock denim
pants with a white tank and matching hat
Kendall if this modeling thing doesn't
work out you could be a horseback rider
like a real Pro your commentary is
insane of course Kindle's equestrian
side was well documented on Keeping Up
with the Kardashians do you remember I
remember that what else we remember when
E.T caught up with five-year-old Kendall
at home and Kylie was her riding partner
look over wave to the camera say goodbye
bye bye we're out of here back to 2023 A
source told E.T that Kenny's doing great
since her breakup with Devin Booker last
year and now she's enjoying her time
with Bad Bunny
[Music]
with another source adding the two are
attracted to each other and definitely
have a flirty Vibe it's still new but
they're enjoying each other's company
and like each other I like to keep my
private life pretty private yeah don't
expect the flirty Vibes that pop up on
season three of the Kardashians it all
comes back to protecting my piece just
sit from a really young age I think both
Kylie and I kind of knew what we wanted
to keep off the show or what we wanted
to keep to ourselves and um yeah I think
that it's kind of as simple as that also
simple a classic Day date of horsing
around with a new love
[Music]
thank you